[Music]
in gasps defense nears oh my god did
someone fart on someone I was definitely
thinking fossil fuel that's much better
submitted by all the Angelenos is that
what we're calling us yeah he knows
well you guys are I'm us I'm a sacrament
while you come casey considers himself
an Angeleno most Angelenos aren't
Angelenos though you know technically
I'm an orange a Countian mm-hmm
you know it's very evident about how
many people are in this city holiday
times because everybody goes back yes it
was so dead yes and the city was amazing
I'm talking to David something to them
yeah yeah our [ __ ] freeways you know
how many people are in LA County now
stop moving to LA it's full you know how
many people are in LA County now I'm
gonna to many ten million four million
in LA City no mom no mom [ __ ] me today
you're right these t-shirts down man
don't [ __ ] you won't get the sound yeah
like don't [ __ ] me today that's just the
right fine the right font the right code
and then vodka eh you see like
Vietnamese I got some shirts but a
Megamall calm hey go check that out
mother may go mom yeah but a mega mall
car that type oh oh I don't even
officially launched it yet
it's like up and running because by the
time this video is up it's gonna be
launched right along a warehouse Donna
get ready guys it's funny cause like you
like at least have the domain name proof
point yeah anyway
a woman was arrested after pulling a
knife on a man who complained about her
farts so when does happen to Bart yeah
what I've heard about this man joy that
was me apart you know she never farted
she never ever farted in front of me so
this day I've never smelled or even I
can't do it right though
I can't you can you also give a burial
that same advice too because that gonna
be part in front of me like a [ __ ]
did you don't like it it's nothing I
don't like it I just don't understand
she parts in front of me I would like
either a heads up or for her to
recognize that she did it on purpose
because this is what she'll do it ago
and she goes oops
so this [ __ ] right here always
says when he farts oops I didn't know it
even came out so you're saying you push
it out there no okay he doesn't know
when it comes out when I fart there's
different types there is the type of
pushing on my I feel it and then it
comes out right then there's times where
like I'm watching TV I shift my weight
it comes out there's the time I watch
something funny haha laughs and it comes
out they're all different but then Mario
can't have an accidental part well hers
is oops yeah but they said well but she
pushed it out see the part missing is
the timing of it it was I just forget
there's people around me and then she
was like oops there just don't smell or
anything I just find it very odd that
she said she just goes we're just having
a conversation right I should just play
yeah and I'm like just part and she goes
I think so eight year old woman like
really about I could relay always know
what I'm about to find I don't you he
forgets that there's people around cuz
she's so comfortable I was just me ya
know cuz then how would she not know
that she farted that's a she's in her
brain that's happy to me so Kasey and I
we have this thing since the beginning
of the relationship oh that's a big fart
someone's never fart in front of each
other at least not on purpose the only
time that it look getting over yeah I
couldn't ever say you guys been sticking
to it
yeah but they like
it's okay it's like when it accidentally
comes out like let's say we're falling
asleep and then like some like a little
fart comes out we're like oh [ __ ] my far
too much sleep a lot
deep diving it kills me cuz I'm still
awake like a laughing cuz there's times
where I'm sleepy and then like I could
feel the bubble
we're situation about that is though is
the fact that now and that is cold she
has to make a choice whether she's gonna
escape it to the cult or just withstand
the [ __ ] yah we have our separate
blanket so it's okay but it just sucks
when he turns that I'm like you know
when you turn it goes that way man you
know I read that the average human for
it's 14 times a day whoa that means
you're holding it harder parts every
single day that's a lot about them like
three or four do that's so bad maybe one
of the greatest feelings on earth is to
fart it feels very sin specially
sometimes like your butthole itches but
then when you're wiping thorough wipe
like crazy dude there's [ __ ] red on
the tissue it's in pain that's why it it
should say something right now it's very
rare you see Joe with a disgusted face
of you right now because the last time
my butthole aged was when I didn't wipe
thoroughly hmm no do you guys ever
remember that episode from South Park
where Kenny died because he held in all
these farts I saw that I'm gonna die and
I'll die [ __ ] a lady died a lady I
thought you died oh oh it's just gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] be dead I'll be dead but
you're gonna be a ghost all embarrassed
because you aren't
we dead no but since I saw it when I was
a kid I was like oh my god I hope I
don't die one day but I still hold in my
part anyway I think I remember when I
was like 20 I was like worried I really
encourage people to consider it leave
now I kind of think about it but then
like my threshold for holding it is so
short now that I'm just like [ __ ] no
even I think like we have this because I
you don't let them fart no she'll fire
oh my god it's like rotten eggs I can
think it's like your heart damn I so bad
even healthy that's all so for him like
sometimes they'll come out by accident
we're just like dude why'd you do that
we're in the car where does he laugh he
does funny but he knows it like you know
it's just don't fart in front of each
other like excuse yourself
fart somewhere else or there's no one in
that room we're okay with you call it
the sound it's not this yeah I don't
care the sound it's the smell and the
inconsiderate part of like just got to
be able to like walk across the room you
gotta fart and you can't come back right
away either you gotta like you drag it
out this guy doesn't wait it out and now
I'll keep what he does now he has to
pull down his pants take off his
underwear spread his ass cheeks I don't
think you understand like how bad his
farts are his farts are so bad I
guarantee we shut this light off right
we have like infrared goggles his spark
comes out as a angry pirate like this
thank you my fart I'm a temperature you
can pie stick a thermometer in it and
unplug like 120 degrees imagine that's
what the pyramids were is like someone
had a bad far like bar so then to trap
it - so the future can smell had how bad
this [ __ ] floor it was a [ __ ] let
them fart inside the pyramid it was a
power plant they need to harness the
energy of the fire the methane anyway
this story here taking place in Florida
oh no this woman named Ginetta Ginetta
Ginetta she's a lot
37 years old I was waiting in lines
she's waiting in line at a dollar store
and a nearby customer got really upset
because she just farted loudly and
that's when Ginetta pulls out a small
holding knife out of her told the victim
she was going to gut him while moving as
if he was she got embarrassed Oh
bending her fart she was just like
believe it's a person - yeah it's like
she has no regrets is that a tattoo
teardrop yeah kill people
- teardrops she killed somebody damn
look at her eyebrows though her eyebrows
is like you see that [ __ ] yeah like this
one kind of exists though it eroded yeah
cuz that looks like the person who took
the photo said did you really stab
somebody over a fart as she goes what
you've been so sup well she didn't stab
so she just threatened and so she got
arrested and charged with aggravated
assault with a deadly weapon without
intent to kill oh my god that's her
otter did their order wait so she farted
she farted somebody else gave her [ __ ]
for it so she pulled out a knife someone
else farted and she got accused she's I
do the booking for I thought somebody
else fired she got pissed that she was
like no to help out of her fart says you
have to be that she protected like a
child like somebody made fun of her
child she grabbed that full space smell
it tell me it smells good you got so
bruised oh yeah she was gonna kill for
it
I mean it was scary a person defending
their fart in a line of the dollar store
is that's just the [ __ ] movie the
whole movie
like a short film for sure but like
that's a [ __ ] standoff right there
that's an intense all I'm saying if she
was embarrassed and now like she's viral
news everyone now knows that she farted
like more I don't know what the knife
looks like but I know she farted oh man
that's so funny she probably has some
like really crazy childhood situation
about like farts that really just [ __ ]
her up because that's like really bug
about your childhood fart syndrome
people pull a knife on somebody for that
[ __ ] to a sob story
it's a fork and a knife all right man
try to go for a bit of a reach there
dude at the [ __ ] dollar store and
that's also where you can buy those
candles what if it was the cashier the
whole time and they're just like dude
it's a whoopee cushion this is a dollar
store whoopee although store is always a
weird place to be at because some of
them are really nice which is a very few
but majority of them
it's scary dude it's a little weird is
it worse than Walmart you've been
Rudolph strobe before I've been a long
time oh really it was one in Palm
Springs that we went to it's nice I
liked it there are some there are some
dollar stores that are like yeah it
really comes down not to the place or
anything it comes down to the type of
people the community of people that go
into space right then yeah yeah yeah
dollar stores I have like sketchy
neighborhoods or sketchy dollar stores I
saw so one of my favorite taco doors
that I go to there's a dollar store next
to it and that's where you usually Park
there was a dude that I thought was
knocked the [ __ ] out on the floor I
thought like somebody beat his ass
you're just sleeping in the middle of
street it's like usually people when
they sleep in the middle of street they
usually sleep off to the side this dude
had a cart and he was just he stacked up
by some black plastic bags he was just
laying like this so I was like legit
wandering a baz when they call like an
ambulance just left but what if he was
snoring so he just fell asleep in the
middle of the street and those are the
type of dollar stores you should
probably stay away
[Music]